terrorisme deux arrestations importante
dit on hier à paris annoncée par la
présidence de la république sondages
négatifs pour le chef de l'état et le
gouvernement pologne le général joseph
ce qui lie la levée de l'état de siège
au calme le 31 cyclisme sur piste
alain bondue champion du monde bonsoir
ce terrorisme là comme les autres ne
trouvera devant lui c'était le 17 août
une phrase très appuyé conjuguer la
première personne du président françois
mitterrand
c'était quelques jours après l'attentât
de la rue des rosiers
hier soir quatre lignes rédigées au nom
de la présidence de la république
faisait état de deux arrestations jugées
importantes dans les milieux du
terrorisme international
rien de moins rien de plus par tactique
il fallait informer sans trop en dire et
ne sut que bien plus tard
où comment et par qui l'opération fut
effectuée ce matin même l'appartement du
82 rue diderot à vincennes faisait
encore l'objet de minutieuses recherches
c'est ici qu'ils hier soir vers 18h30
une cinquantaine d'hommes du gign ont
arrêté deux hommes âgés de 25 à 26 ans
selon certains témoignages dans cette
opération menée semble-t-il sur des
indications des services du
contre-espionnage de nombreux documents
explosifs ont été saisis aux dires mêmes
des gendarmes
il y avait là de quoi faire sauter tout
l'immeuble uniforme et puis d
des personnes en civil on est en baisse
des charges et du bois non ça ne voulait
pas rentrer là-dedans sortir et les
juniors les deux rentrées et de ne pas
rester là parce que ça peut être
dangereux et puis parce qu'on prend à
partie un moment il ya des armes qui
sont qui sont dégainés on cherchera pas
à regarder que l'on a pensé que c'était
pour que vous avez vu vous avez vu proto
sur place non non ne l'a pas vu comme
moi je pensais je pensais qu'il était
qu'il était dans tu penserais d'avoir
connu en anglais mais apparemment il ya
eu la confirmation a été donnée par à 10
inspecteurs aussi a été très bref un ils
étaient encadrés par tonne des gendarmes
que dès que des inspecteurs et les ont
mis dans des voitures sont parties
immédiatement n'a pas le temps de te
voir qui était dans la voiture
quelques heures plus tard une jeune
femme était interpellé à son tour
quant à savoir si ces trois personnes
sont bien au fort de vincennes
actuellement et surtout quelle est leur
importance au plan du terrorisme
international
nulle information n'a encore filtré sur
cette opération menée de bout en bout
par la gendarmerie
donc pas d'information nouvelle sur
l'identité sur la qualité des personnes
arrêtées il semble que le secrétariat à
la sécurité publique de monsieur
française qui est suivi toute la sphère
il semble que ce soient les gendarmes du
gign du commandant prouteau qu'ils
soient les auteurs de l'opération
il apparaît aussi quelques amertumes du
côté de la brigade criminelle de paris
de n'avoir pas été mis au courant
curieusement tout en maintenant le
silence officiel sur l'enquêté
deux ministres messieurs hernu et
françaises qui ont tenu à féliciter tous
les services concernés par la lutte
contre le terrorisme
et puis on vient d'apprendre que l'
enquête sur l'arrestation a été confiée
à la brigade criminelle de paris et à la
gendarmerie cela sous l'autorité du
parquet de créteil pour ne pas manquer à
la tradition la rentrée politique se
nourrit de sondages deux hebdomadaires
livre des résultats somme toute
concordants le nouvel observateur rendez
compte
avant-hier d'une perte de confiance
envers la gauche l'hebdomadaire le point
aujourd'hui s'appuie sur un sondage ifop
qui enregistre une très nette baisse
d'opinions favorables à monsieur
mitterrand pour la première fois les
opinions favorables sont inférieurs aux
défavorable certes le sondage a été
réalisé avant que l'on ait connaissance
des dernières décisions économiques du
gouvernement
mais qu'on le veuille ou non peu la mare
les résultats sont plutôt mauvais non
fait
les français grogne essentiellement à
cause de la situation économique les
entrepreneurs les commerçants les
artisans sans doute parce que les prix
des produits qu'ils vendent ont été
bloquées pour quatre mois les salariés
parce que leurs revenus ont été bloquées
pour quatre mois c'est assez clair
l'austérité même si le mot n'a jamais
été prononcé et une potion assez amer
que les français quelles que soient
leurs bulletins de vote
c'est aussi l'enseignement de ces
sondages ont du mal à avaler leur face à
cette réaction
que peut faire le pouvoir il y avait le
choix entre deux solutions ou bien
offrir à la rentrée quelques douceurs si
j'ose dire pour faire oublier ce goût
amer ou bien mener la même politique qui
ne passe pas forcément par un blocage
permanent mais au moins par une
modération des prix et des revenus
et bien c'est cette deuxième voie qu'il
a choisie au risque d'être impopulaire
le risque est grand nous sommes à
quelques mois des municipales pourquoi
ce choix tout simplement parce que le
gouvernement est confiant qu'il croit
aux bienfaits à terme de cette rigueur
l indice du mois de juillet le
confortent dans cette détermination une
expression entendue très récemment à
l'hôtel matignon
nous sommes décidés à livrer bataille
une expression martial qui illustre
cette volonté de lutter sur deux fronts
le front économique avec la rigueur
imposée à tous et le front psychologique
le président de la république et le
premier ministre vont monter en première
ligne et expliquer aux français les
choix économiques qu'ils ont fait mais
les deux hommes savent très bien que
cette explication aussi brillante soit
elle ne convaincra ces français qui
doute que si elle est accompagnée dans
cette bataille qu'il livre contre
l'inflation et le chômage que si elle
est accompagnée de bulletins de victoire
c'est à dire de bons indices avaient eu
deux déclarations j'ajoute à votre
commentaire paul monsieur delanoë du ps
se dit que ce serait pire si on change
de politique
et puis monsieur peyrefitte alain
peyrefitte député rpr de la scène emma
considère que la situation de la france
se dégrade dans tous les domaines au
cours de la réunion des ministres des
finances de la communauté économique
européenne au danemark singer le
ministre français de l'économie monsieur
jacques delors a déclaré que les taux
d'intérêt sur le marché monétaire en
france sont appelés à baisser dès lundi
messieurs de l'or n'a cependant pas
voulu donner de précisions sur l'ampleur
l'importance de cette baisse en pologne
deux jours avant l'anniversaire de la
signature des accords de gdansk le 31
août pour beaucoup l'affrontement entre
solidarité des forces de l'ordre sera
difficilement évitable aujourd'hui le
général jaruzelski a lancé un appel au
calme me liant directement la levée de
l'état
siège à la fin de l'année au maintien de
la paix sociale le 31 août de varsovie
une correspondance téléphonique de
michel castex aujourd'hui la constituer
aucune surprise liée directement à la
tournure dépendra finalement les
événements york aucune atteinte à
l'ordre public la nouvelle et data ciel
avant la fin de l'année a assuré les
terrasses pour aussitôt ajouter
en pratique la détention qui décidera et
la situation ce sont les gens qui la
grèce le message est clair et la
population manifeste dit les nombreux
survienne la levée de la loi martiale
n'est pas pour demain
même flou en ce qui concerne les
syndicats le mouvement syndical va
réactiver whitney sur des bases et
rennes a dit le numéro un de ces
patients avaient en tout cas sur la base
des propos quasi nulles que solidarité
appelle à manifester mardi pour le 2e
anniversaire des accords de ce camp
au liban et en israël il s'agit bien des
dernières journées de la fin d'un
conflit monsieur b guinée parti se
reposer une dizaine de kilomètres de la
frontière libanaise monsieur charest le
ministre israélien de la défense est aux
états unis où il multiplie déclarations
fracassantes ainsi cette phrase publiée
par le washington post nous ne
permettrons jamais un autre état
palestinien les réfugiés palestiniens
ont déjà une patrie la transjordanie du
roi hussein on ne touchera pas à la
judée et la samarie ni à gaza n'y
comptez pas conclu monsieur sharon dans
le journal américain le washington post
un site indique que l'évacuation des
combattants palestiniens se poursuit les
hommes politiques parlent déjà de
l'après vers août philippe chatenet ses
fidèles de l'armée de libération de la
palestine 1500 hommes environ ont quitté
beyrouth ouest ce matin par convois
routiers vers la syrie les bersaglieri
italiens de la force multinationale ont
fourni une escorte très puissante aux
200 véhicules transportant les
palestiniens et il n'y a pas eu
d'incident lors de la traversée des
zones tenues par les phalangistes et les
israéliens
seul détail un tant soit peu provocateur
des dizaines de drapeaux israéliens
apparu pendant la nuit
pavoisé le parcours du convoi entre la
galerie semman et les lignes syriennes à
sofa avec le départ de ce groupe plus de
8700 combattants palestiniens ont quitté
beyrouth depuis le début de l'opération
d'évacuation le 21 août
plus de 3000 fedayin ont été accueillis
par la syrie un millier par les deux
yémen encore mille par la tunisie 500
par le soudan 250 par la jordanie et 150
par l'irak
les estimations du nombre de faits dane
qui reste encore à beyrouth varie de
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
qui devront tous avoir quitté le liban
samedi prochain
quant à yasser arafat que l'on voit ici
recevant des femmes venus des camps
palestiniens du sud vivant il partirait
demain farmer escortés par des navires
de guerre français italiens ou
américains
mais on ne connaît pas sa destination
immédiate arafat a affirmé qu'il
partirait je cite au vu et au su de tout
le monde
beyrouth ouest du prêt par des adieux
spectaculaire avant sont des femmes mais
pratiquement tous les autres dirigeants
de la résistance palestinienne ont déjà
quitté beyrouth pour le port syrien de
tartous georges habache nayef hawatmeh
et ahmad gibril sont arrivés hier avec
ce groupe de fedayins abou jihad et abou
iyad sont attendus ici ce soir le ton
des premières déclarations de ses
leaders est extrêmement dur
georges habache dénonce l'impuissance et
la trahison de certains pays arabes
ahmad gibril quand elle lui affirme que
les palestiniens ont quitté une tranchée
pour une autre et que la lutte contre
israël va continuer les militaires
français de la force d'interposition au
liban ont reçu très officiellement les
félicitations de charles hernu le miz de
la défense le drapeau de la france est
honoré par tous la valeur du contingent
français est imposée à tous a dit
monsieur charles est revenu à beyrouth
entre ceux qui partent et ceux qui
restent c'est à chaque fois les mêmes
scènes jusqu'au dernier moment bien des
hommes ignorent ou dire on est plus
grave que deviendront leurs femmes leurs
familles à beyrouth pour antenne 2 le
reportage de patricia cost et patrice du
tertre
jour après jour ils continuent à s'en
aller vite sans faire d'histoire souvent
ils n'apprennent où on les emmène que la
veille de leur départ
leur organisation fonctionne sur le
secret et le contrôle la plupart s'y
plie ce vieil homme nous dira peu
importe d'où je viens et où je fais je
vais de bataille en bataille pourtant
beaucoup aimé vivre à beyrouth
c'est beaucoup des guerres c'est facile
on avait eu on a eu un coût des guerres
qui a passé à nous en 78 avant un grand
merci est maintenant et on part pour que
presse le liban un peu pour le sauver on
peut pas rester ici comme ça à beyrouth
avec les citoyens une bombe
les gens civile on peut pas
alors ceci vite de partir parce que on a
passé six boutons ici et on a beaucoup d
amis des libanais notre frère qui nous a
aidés et qui sont ici pour dire au
revoir tout ça à la mer a tous des
places que je connais c'est très
difficile c'est trop vite sur le tout
faire je nageais atteint il faut que je
pars à l'est dans la montagne je passais
de temps avec les amis en parfait comme
ça
beaucoup trop de choses et autres des
gens je vérifiais il ne pense qu'on va
partir
classé
sempé
la barre du temps
très bien c'était très bien passé il
nous a fallu faire
attaquants
les familles sont pas comme les tarifs
des gens qui étaient
à part tuer comme tu es
je sais
non très bien
situation et réduire
eliane fait inouï et seul qui rassure
qui par l'association très dur mais
désespéré là je sors pas désespérer de
l'association je peux dire oui
selon les accords d'évacuation les
femmes et les enfants doivent rester à
beyrouth
la plupart le font déchiré leur
organisation leur ont dit qu'elle
retrouvera bientôt leur mari mais pour
l'instant elle vous restez seul l'ol
paie compte secrètement sur elle pour
continuer à occuper le terrain
personne ne le dira ouvertement car
l'avenir est si incertain
nous les femmes de combattant connu nous
avons peur sur les phalangistes viennent
nous chercher dans les temps est ce que
vous allez vous défendre si vous vous
sentez menacés
oui je serai obligé de me défendre son
lancement est-ce que vous avez après
vous servir d'une arme
les femmes palestiniennes elles vont
bientôt devoir abandonner leur
appartement vide du centre où elle
s'était réfugiée est retournée chez elle
dans les camps mais les camps il ne
reste pratiquement plus rien
eux ils sont revenus ce matin pendant
les bombardements ils ont été se cacher
sous les arbres sur la route vous allez
faire
elle ne va rien faire
elle ne peut rien faire d'ailleurs les
16 elle va réfléchir qu'elle ne demande
pas d'argent l olp les mains de l'état
faisant passer le message il ya aucun
membre de sa famille qui appartient à l
olp lui il ne demande plus rien il
attend
au fond des camps de sabra chatila
bonjour âge n'y ait des morts aussi
attendent sous les décombres
mon reportage de patricia kaas et
patrice du tertre en france pour les
retours de vacances je n'ai pas grand
chose de plus vous dire qu'hier soir
tout simplement sur la route ça ne s'est
plutôt pas trop mal passée suite
maintenant de notre enquête bilan sur la
saison touristique hier c'était la côte
d'azur et la cuisine et l'huile ce soir
voyant la côte normande et la cuisine au
beurre à deauville le bilan provisoire
est assez bon une fréquentation en
hausse en grande partie grâce aux
étrangers l'enquète dans régaler
l'affluence estivale ici est étroitement
liée aux caprices du temps à deux heures
de paris par l'autoroute
un coup de fil suffit à décider si oui
ou non la météo mais rick que l'on parte
arpenter les fameuses planches du bord
de mer un chiffre précise le caractère
versatile de la clientèle
la durée moyenne des séjours a été de
deux jours et demi en juillet et de cinq
jours en août 5 jours du fait des
courses hippiques
nous avons fait un mois de juillet très
satisfaisant il a fait un temps superbe
et grâce notamment à la fréquentation
d'une clientèle étrangère qui est venu
en nombre supérieur aux autres années à
peu près de l'ordre de 30 à 35 % de
clientèle est étrangère
ja ont fait un mois d'août toujours
aussi brillant puisque les classiques
traditionnels de l'animation et des
courses à deauville font que nous fixons
une clientèle de haut niveau et des
qualités qui est revenue fidèles cette
année encore à deauville 750 francs la
nuit c'est un minimum dans les hôtels de
grand luxe
ils ont affiché complet cette saison la
clientèle n'a même pas protesté
parait-il après l'augmentation des taxes
de 25% visant cette catégorie
d'établissements chiffre en hausse
également au casino le deuxième de
france +15 % sur les jeux + 10 % sur les
entrées à côté de cette clientèle
fortunée des bourses plus modestes qui
éprouvent beaucoup de difficultés à se
loger et se nourrir au moindre prix
cette partie de la côte normande est
plutôt mal équipé pour le tourisme de
masse à deauville sur 15 cents chambres
d'hôtel
on en compte plus de 1000 dans la
catégorie luxe et grand luxe 3 et 4
étoiles
la clientèle s'est comporté pratiquement
comme l'année dernière avec peut-être
peut-être un petit peu plus peut-être un
petit peu plus d'attention quand même
dans les dépenses c'est à dire à savoir
peut-être un petit peu moins de 20
et peut-être plus de petits menus que le
repas la carte m'enfin c'est pas quand
même c'est pas flagrant si vous voulez
d'autres façons n'y a pas de chute par
rapport à l'année dernière
les restaurateurs globalement satisfait
il est vrai qu'un menu affiché ici à un
prix modeste apparaît souvent comme
suspect pour le commerce des chiffres
également en hausse
si l'on constate un mieux 15% pour
l'alimentation
c'est encore mieux 20% pour les
commerces de luxe
seul nuage dans cette saison presque
idyllique l'immobilier de loisirs là on
assiste à une récession dans les ventes
supérieures à 400 mille francs
cela s'explique au dessous de 400 mille
francs il n'y a pas grand chose sur le
marché sur le thème médecine et
nucléaire pour la troisième fois
plusieurs milliers de personnes sont
rassemblées à partir d'aujourd'hui à
paris afin de comparer des expériences
de mieux étudier tout l'intérêt de la
porte de la technique nucléaire à la
médecine et à la biologie technique
encore récente qui peut permettre de
gros progrès dans la connaissance du
corps mais jusqu'ici les méthodes
radiographie classique et même le
scanner permettait d'obtenir des
renseignements sur la forme des organes
où la densité des tissus il était
quasiment impossible d'étudier l'état
fonctionnel de ses organes
l'injection de substances émettant une
très faible radioactivité a ouvert des
portes nouvelle à condition de choisir
un traceur radioactif approprié il est
maintenant facile d'étudier en temps
réel la vie propre à chaque organe comme
par exemple sur ces images la fonction
cardiaque volume de sang effectuée et a
dû mieux car activités des ventricules
et cetera informatique aidant rien de
plus simple que d'observer en détail une
région précise de cet organe
la palette de cette technique est
particulièrement large et prometteuse
ainsi la thyroïde quasiment impossible à
observer avec des radiographies
classique est devenu un examen naudin
grâce à la médecine nucléaire
autre exemple de l'efficacité de ces
méthodes
la détection précoce des métastases
osseuses de cancer la médecine nucléaire
permet un diagnostic précis plusieurs
mois avant que la radiographie ne
révèlent ces mêmes métastases
pourtant on peut se demander si l'emploi
de substances radioactives pour l'examen
par exemple du cerveau ne présente pas
un certain danger pour l'individu à qui
l'on injecte ses produits de suivre des
règles qui sont extrêmement pressés et
qui concerne aussi bien le type de
produit les mêmes que nous injectons que
les doses de ne pas ou n'utilisions quai
des queyries des produits qui ont une
période de vie courte ce qui signifie
par exemple que pour plus de 90% des
examens que nous faisons le technicien
99m que mon que nous on palio a perdu la
moitié de son activité bout de six
heures et au bout de trois jours il
n'est plus mesurable
d'autre part les deux que nous affectons
sont des doses faibles qui sont bien
connues que nous ne devons pas dépasser
qui sont inscrits dans le règlement et
troisièmement ces produits sont éliminés
par le métabolisme normale de
l'organisme et ont quitté l'organisme
humeur au bout d'un délai très bref
donc pas de danger dont il n'y a pas de
danger les deux finalement les hommes de
radiations que nous délivrons leçons
sont de l'ordre de celle qu'on donne en
radiologie
en france la médecine nucléaire n'a peut
être pas encore l'importance qu'ils
devraient avoir
il n'existe que 125 centres pour 53
millions d'habitants souhaitons que ce
troisième congrès fasse évoluer cette
situation congrès à paris depuis
aujourd'hui porte de versailles
plus de peur que de mal pour les cinq
spéléologues bloqués depuis vendredi
matin dans le gouffre berger à autrans
dans l'isère selon les secouristes les
spéléologues devrait regagner la surface
ce soir par leurs propres moyens
la décrue des eaux d'une cascade d en
avait empêché jusqu'à présent en sport
la france compte un nouveau champion du
monde en cyclisme professionnel le
championnat se déroulait leicester en
angleterre
du a remporté la finale cet après midi
après les deux médailles de bronze
gagnée par jeannie longo en poursuite et
il y avait 40 vitesse professionnels le
français alain bondue offert à la france
une belle médaille d'or
landu qui va battre en finale de
poursuite professionnels danois heinz
orsted au terme d'une course à l'énergie
vendue va remporter son deuxième titre
de champion du monde avec un temps de 6
minutes 03 secondes 76 centièmes soit 43
centièmes de mieux que son adversaire
bondues qui aura fourni un effort
terrible avant de s'écrouler
d'épuisement une fois la ligne franchie
en tout cas un grand bravo pour aller
manger
le sport automobile a été lui beaucoup
moins favorable aux couleurs juste en se
mettant une très faible radioactivité a
ouvert des portes nouvelle à condition
de choisir un traceur radioactif
approprié il est maintenant facile
d'étudier en temps réel la vie propre à
chaque organe comme par exemple sur ces
images
la fonction cardiaque volume le sens
éjecté et a du myocarde activités des
ventricules et cetera informatique
aidant rien de plus simple que
d'observer en détail une région précise
de cet organe
la palette de cette technique est
particulièrement large et prometteuse
ainsi la thyroïde quasiment impossible à
observer avec des radiographies
classique est devenu un examen naudin
grâce à la médecine nucléaire
autre exemple de l'efficacité de ces
méthodes
la détection précoce de métastases
osseuses de cancer un médecine nucléaire
permet un diagnostic précis plusieurs
mois avant que la radiographie ne révèle
ce même métastases pourtant on peut se
demander si l'emploi de substances
radioactives pour l'examen par exemple
du cerveau ne présente pas un certain
danger pour l'individu à qui l'on
injecte ses produits de suivre des
règles qui sont extrêmement précises et
qui concerne aussi bien le type de
produit les mêmes que nous injectons que
les doses de ne pas ou n'utilisions
hockey des périls des produits qui ont
une période de
courte ce qui signifie par exemple que
pauvre plus de 90% des examens que nous
faisons
le technicien 99m que mieux que nous
employons a perdu la moitié de son
activité vous disais et au bout de trois
jours il n'est plus mesurable
d'autre part les deux que nous injectons
sont des doses faibles qui sont bien
connues que nous ne devons pas dépasser
qui sont inscrits dans le règlement et
troisièmes noces et pour lui sont
éliminés par le métabolisme normale de
l'organisme et ont quitté l'organisme
humain
au bout d'un délai très bref donc pas de
danger dont il n'y a pas de danger les
doses finalement les docks de radiations
que nous délivrons leçons sont de
l'ordre de celle qu'on donne de
radiologie en france la médecine
nucléaire n'a peut être pas encore
l'importance qu'ils devraient avoir
il n'existe que 125 centres pour 53
millions d'habitants souhaitons que ce
troisième congrès fasse évoluer cette
situation congrès à paris depuis
aujourd'hui pas mais porte de versailles
plus de peur que de mal pour les cinq
spéléologues bloqués depuis vendredi
matin dans le gouffre berger à autrans
dans l'isère selon les secouristes les
spéléologues devrait regagner la surface
ce soir par leurs propres moyens
la décrue des eaux d'une cascade d en
avait empêché jusqu'à présent en sport
la france quand un nouveau champion du
monde en cyclisme professionnel le
championnat se déroulait leicester en
angleterre
alain bondue a remporté la finale cet
après midi après les deux médailles de
bronze gagnée par jeannie longo en
poursuite et y avait 40 vitesse
professionnels le français alain bondue
offert à la france une belle médaille
d'or vendues qui va battre en finale de
poursuite professionnels danois 1
ted au terme d'une course à l'énergie
conduit va remporter son deuxième titre
de champion du monde avec un temps de 6
minutes 03 secondes 76 centièmes soit 43
centièmes de mieux que son adversaire
dans du pur a fourni un effort terrible
avant de s'écouler d'épuisement une fois
la ligne franchie
en tout cas un grand bravo pour aller
manger le sport automobile a été dû
beaucoup moins favorables aux couleurs
françaises c'est en effet le finlandais
keke rosberg qui a gagné à dijon le
grand prix de suisse cet après-midi
crampes aux deux fils formule les
renault de prosternant en pole position
sur la grille de départ on s'attendait
cet après-midi un duel serré entre les
deux pilotes français et c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé pendant 72
tours exactement alain prost devant a
renoué fille kate était bien décidé à
gagner ce grand prix de suisse pour se
rapprocher de didier pironi au
classement du championnat du monde
mais à l'arrière et non pas réagir celui
qui est le mieux placé pour inquiéter
didier pironi il s'agit du finlandais
keke rosberg qui sur sa williams va
réaliser une fin de course admirable
rossberg va d'abord passé arnould en
train de s'arrêter aux soixante
quatorzième tour avant d'exercer un
pressing terrible sur alain prost
toujours en tête à ce moment de la
course alain prost qui va céder à deux
tours de la fin
et lors la course est terminée rosberg
va remporter son premier grand prix
devant prost et niki lauda une belle
victoire de revers mais surtout des
voitures à moteur atmosphérique sur les
moteurs turbo au classement du
championnat du monde des conducteurs
rosberg passe pironi alain prost se
retrouve lui 3e à 11 points pour prost
le titre de champion du monde n'est pas
complètement perdu
toujours des chances c'est sûr mais
voilà c'était vraiment très vraiment
très juste qui applique de course aux
points de retard hier je peux plus me
permettre de gagner il faut aussi que
rosberg a besoin d'une fois ça s'est
quand même
c'est quand même possible je pense il a
quand même la baraka est ce qu'il faudra
compter avec à la clé est ce qu'il
aurait été possible pour vous par
exemple de bouchonner pendant les deux
derniers tours est ce que matériellement
c'était peu cette aventure était
complètement inconduisible j'étais
ralenti partout dans tous les virages et
surtout dans les virages à gauche
quand il m'a passé j'étais de toute
façon à l'extérieur de la piste au
ralenti je ne voulais absolument rien
c'est un nouveau record de france du 400
m haies pour chantal rey gac amélioré
son record de france du 400 m haies
féminin lors de la réunion d'athlétisme
de stuttgart où elle a réalisé 55
secondes et 28 centièmes le précédent
record était de 56 secondes 40 centièmes
les joueurs de l'équipe de france de
football qui affronteront mardi en match
amical la pologne ont été largement
dépouillés de leur a fait ce que l'on
nomme un rat d'hôtel a entassés pêle
mêle argent liquide cartes de crédit et
équipements dans un seul sac celui de
jean castaneda
le gardien de but saint-etienne je crois
bien que le surnom de castaneda est le
shirk voilà sans doute pourquoi la
dépêche qualifie le voleur de rats
d'hôtel
voyons maintenant les résultats du
tiercé qui se courait cet après midi à
deauville dans la 3e course aussi les
images de l'arrivée dans l'ordre c'est
le numéro 20 qui devance le numéro 16
qui devance lui-même le numéro 17 25 16
17 dans l'ordre vous voyez s'inscrire
les rapports pour 5 francs 38 mille 0 97
francs et dans un ordre différent 3940
de francs 50 jours pour 5 francs
voyons maintenant la météo elizabeth
pour demain oui bien demain c'est ce
n'est plus vraiment l'été cela fera sans
doute plaisir à ceux qui doivent
reprendre le travail mais une série de
perturbations va traverser la france
dans les jours qui viennent et nous
apporter du mauvais temps alors dès
demain matin et bien ce mauvais temps
sera sur les régions proches de la mer
du nord et de la manche
et puis au cours de la journée ce
mauvais temps va se déplacer et à la mi
journée c'est ce que nous voyons sur la
carte et viendra septembre des régions
qui vont des ardennes à l'alsace à
l'aquitaine donc sur ces régions
beaucoup de nuages avec des risques de
pluies et même des orages en revanche
plus au nord à ce moment là et bien
réapparition d'un temps assez agréable
avec de belles éclaircies plus au sud du
beau temps beaucoup de soleil mais un
nouveau désagrément dans la soirée
puisque une nouvelle perturbation
arrivée de la manche et dans la soirée
donc il vient l'amènera à nouveau
beaucoup de nuages sur en gros sur le
quart nord-ouest de la france avec là
aussi des risques de pluie les
températures et bien dans les régions
qui verront le soleil demain pas de
changement c'est à dire principalement
sur les bords de la méditerranée en
corse 26-27 jusqu'à 29 degrés à bastia
ailleurs et bien là où le soleil sera
absent quelques degrés de moins
qu'aujourd'hui pour demain après midi la
météo nationale ne prévoit pas plus de
16 en normandie 18 en bretagne et dans
le nord 21 à paris voilà en météo les
jours se suivent et parfois ne se
ressemblent pas du tout demain nous
serons le lundi 30 août dans les
endroits elle voudra bien se montrer
bien le soleil se lèvera à 7h05 pour se
coucher à 20h37 et ce sera la
saint-fiacre la fête des jardins
merci elizabeth je vous rappelle cette
information nous est parvenue au début
de ce journal l'enquète sur
l'arrestation annoncée hier soir de deux
terroristes internationaux annoncée par
la présidence de la république a été
confiée à la brigade criminelle de la
police judiciaire de paris en
association avec la section de
recherches de la gendarmerie de paris ce
qui mettra peut-être fin à quelques
grands du côté des policiers la garde à
vue
d'autre part des personnes arrêtées je
rappelle qu'il ya deux personnes -deux
qui ont été arrêtés plus une troisième
personne une jeune femme qui c'est qui
s'est rendue à l'appartement
la garde à vue des personnes arrêtées a
été prolongée de 24 heures c'est à dire
jusqu'à lundi soir le dernier journal
sera 23 heures il vous sera présentée
par jean claude renaud et puis c'est la
fin des vacances d'août a lancé le
retour de nos amis bernard langlois
demain antenne de midi 12h 45 puis un
autre ami patrick poivre d'arvor a
factor bonsoir merci